on the Eve of the New Hampshire primary, which
is tonight, Donald Trump did a rally in New
Hampshire and it was really something to behold.
Now we're going to go through some of the,
the the key moments.
And for me at this point, you know, the wacky
part is less about what Trump says, although
obviously Trump is wacky and saying absolutely
ridiculous things.
It's more about the supporters at this point
who just nod and clap along with whatever
Donald Trump says.
This rally was the epitome of what I would
call Trump culture, where facts don't matter.
Riling up a crowd with red meat that is completely,
uh, a dishonest if not bad.
Actually false is all that matters.
Now to start with, as many of you know, Donald
Trump has a very weird history about talking
about how he finds his daughter Ivanka, very
attractive.
He's even said things before like, you know,
if she weren't my daughter type of stuff,
and we've covered that widely before and once
again, Donald Trump talking about the beauty
of his daughter and he seems to recognize
here because he says, I'm not supposed to
say that.
He seems to recognize that this is something
that is a little weird to be saying again
yesterday talking about Ivanka and now clearly
referencing the fact that he said weird things
about her in the past.
Take a look.
Also a woman that not too many people know,
very powerful, very smart, very beautiful.
Even though I'm not allowed to say that because
she's my daughter, Ivanka Trump
then went, as weird as that was into his normal
attacks on the media, claiming that they never
show the crowd at his rallies.
They only show his face.
What's hilarious is as he started to say that
they were showing the crowd and they continued
to show the crowd during this portion of the
speech
is these guys will never report that
[inaudible]
or even like showing the crowd.
They always show my face.
They never show the crowd, but you know what?
The people can hear the crowd, the people
can hear the crowd.
The crowd of course, visible at the start
and at the end of that 25 second clip during
which Trump says they never show the crowd
at my rallies, and the crowd of course just
loves it.
And of course that's more of the firing up
of his base against the media, which unfortunately
has led to so much hostility against the concept
of a free press more than any president in
recent history.
Donald Trump has really catalyzed and coalesced
a hatred if not disdain for media in the United
States under the guys often a fake news, and
we know the memes that he's used.
Trump then goes on to talk about how undocumented
immigrants have no addresses, which is of
course a strange thing to say, but more importantly,
he seems confused between undocumented immigrants
and homeless people.
We have video.
Remember of Donald Trump being confused between
health insurance and life insurance.
That's a funny and depressing one.
We have videos of Trump being confused about
many different things in this video.
Trump seems about the difference between an
undocumented immigrant and a person who is
homeless.
And then of course he throws in the normal
dehumanizing language that he uses about immigrants,
record numbers that we've ended catch and
release.
You know, catching releases.
You catch an illegal alien by law.
You then take his name and address the have
addresses.
What's your address?
What they don't have addresses.
They come into the country, they don't have
addresses, so you take his name.
Trump then raises the lie that he simply won't
stop telling, which is that in 2016 buses
full of Massachusetts voters were sent up
to New Hampshire to vote illegally, and that's
the only reason why Hillary Clinton ultimately
defeated Trump by 0.3% there.
It's not because she really won.
It's because Massachusetts voters voted illegally
in New Hampshire.
Now, of course, there's no evidence whatsoever
for that claim, but if you're watching, watch
his audience start to nod with Donald Trump
about the hundreds of buses of Massachusetts
voters sent up to vote illegally, and if you're
listening, you'll of course hear the booing
and the a M audio of his supporters immediately
just falling for this hook, line and sinker.
Because you know you have some pretty strange
election laws here, right?
Remember last time we won the primary tremendously,
we should have won the election, but they
had buses being shipped up from Massachusetts,
hundreds and hundreds of [inaudible]
[inaudible].
I know it was very, very close, even though
they did, but this year, we know we have a
great governor.
Look at how little the truth is worth that
Donald Trump casually lies about hundreds
of buses.
Understand what you hundreds of buses, right
aside from there being no evidence of this,
a lot of these polling places in New Hampshire
are tiny.
They would be completely overwhelmed and paralyzed
by even 10 buses showing up.
Nevermind hundreds of buses being sent up
to New Hampshire, but the crowd doesn't care.
They clap and they boo and they not along
to the lies that Donald Trump tells and then
again riling up the crowd towards possible
violence.
Donald Trump pulls this entire thing about
we're going to protect your guns.
They are going to take all of your guns and
all of your money and all of your stuff.
Take a look
[inaudible]
we're going to protect your second amendment.
By the way, they're going to take away everything.
They're going to take away your wealth.
They're going to take away your guns.
They're going to take away everything.
[inaudible] the
cult of Trumpism.
It's very dangerous.
We wonder how do people believe this stuff?
A guy himself potentially not mentally well
so easily is able to get a stadium full of
people to believe what he says.
Or even if they doubted to rationalize him
saying it.
And this is how cults work, truly.
I mean more and more when you look, there
are more and more cult experts that are looking
at the cult of Trumpism.
And it is reminiscent and so way, so many
ways of, uh, the, uh, you know, the cult leader
who says, April 21st will be the rapture.
We will either be struck down here on earth
or ascend to a life in eternity in heaven
or whatever.
And then April 21st comes and goes and they
rationalize it away with Trump.
It's either, well, the Democrats ruined it,
or the fake news media ruined it.
Or Trump was using it as a metaphor he didn't
literally meet or whatever the case may be.
It is scary stuff.
And this is why I am afraid of violence.
I'm sort of afraid of violence no matter what
happens in November of 2020.
But of course if Donald Trump ultimately loses
and claims that it was rigged, I am very worried
about the real world violence that these folks
are feeling.
Hopefully going to do.
Let me know your thought on that.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this